the deadline to vote is around the
corner
and i know this is a major cause of
yours and i think it's something that
everybody's concerned about right now uh
which is
the number of people that will decide
this election the number of people that
decided the last election
was so razor thin that everyone needs to
understand
how important their vote is it's crucial
oh and
you know it amazes me to hear people say
well i didn't vote because i didn't
think it mattered
and as you mentioned this last election
uh in in some of the swing states the
margin of difference was five
votes per precinct and that wasn't just
unique to this past election i mean i
have been
campaigning in midterm elections and
in the last several elections and i've
looked at the statistics and every time
you look at the margin of victory
because we have such a low
voting percentage in this country that
for every election
at every level we're talking about one
two five 10 50 votes that determine who
your mayor is who your governor
is who your you know council member is
um so every vote absolutely matters and
people just take this for granted
and then when it doesn't turn out the
way they had hoped
uh they're shocked and upset
um but this is a democracy and
yes sometimes it's frustrating and
sometimes it can be alienating i
i get that but i've also traveled the
world
and i've seen other forms of government
and i wouldn't trade our democracy for
anything in the world but in order for
it to work
we need active engaged and informed
citizens who
are ready to do the one pretty simple
thing
which is vote and you can mail it in
you can stay in line if you want you can
vote early
you can do it always yes we could have
more ways to vote it could be easier and
we
hopefully with the right leadership
we'll get um
voting requirements that will be easier
but right now it's pretty easy
it takes some planning um and
and and people can get the information
they need but
we just can't afford for people to take
the attitude that voting doesn't count
uh it it absolutely does